this is the book that helped me escape
my childhood this is the book that i
read when no one in my family or friends
was as mind-blown as i was by how the
universe came to be or how physics works
or how quantum mechanics works this is
the book that started my fascination
with the human brain and made me really
wanted to study neurology for the first
time i've probably read thousands of
books by this point in my life and i
often get asked how to make reading a
habit or how to eat more and usually my
response is well why do you want to do
this at all and the answer to that is
something along the lines of you know
it's good for you while i don't think
that anyone should feel guilty that they
read more or less than other people i
genuinely think that books have changed
the way that my brain works and
therefore i want to share five ways that
books have kind of shifted and changed
my brain and if any one of these sounds
a bit interesting maybe that might give
you a stronger incentive to start
reading number one i think that books
give you the opportunity to have more
friends and as sad as this sounds let me
try to explain especially when i was
younger i did not really have access to
a lot of people it would just be my
family and people that i was with in
school and the chance is that in this
very small group of people you find
someone who matches with each one of
your preferences in life is actually
quite low so when it comes to books i
find that if someone has thought about
it someone else or them has probably
written about it so i don't like the
thought that we should limit our
experiences and interactions with people
with just those with whom we kind of run
into in our day-to-day life we should
kind of broaden that scope into people
who are somewhere else in the world or
have even died and are not alive today
and books definitely allow you to do
this especially non-fiction books feel a
lot like a conversation and therefore
you can kind of explore topics that you
are interested in with someone else with
whom you probably will never get the
chance to meet but that's absolutely
fine because you're getting the pleasure
of their kind of friendship and
interaction you actually might find that
you have a lot more in common with a
philosopher who died 300 years ago in
some ways that you view the world than
with your flatmate i have definitely
formed friendships in some ways with
certain authors or at least their essays
or things that they have written i love
the sentence that we only feel lonely
because experiences like ours are
scattered in the world and actually we
are not that alone and i feel like books
can kind of help unlock that when you
see even with fictional characters
things that people have gone through
might be very similar to things that you
have experienced but no one around you
has done the same thing i feel as though
books in the past have definitely helped
me feel a lot less alone secondly and i
love this one books have created a whole
other fictional reality in my brain i
will use harry potter as an example for
this or i could use aragon for the same
kind of thing but books go into so much
detail about whole other worlds so in my
brain i have this kind of space for
people and places and laws and
connections and histories and stories
that are just as real in a way as the
world i have lived in myself so
sometimes even as an adult if i just
want to kind of escape the present for
like half an hour or an hour all i need
to do is pick up a harry potter book and
i know that i can very easily dip into
this whole other reality which makes so
much sense for me and beyond this i
actually remember what was happening in
my life when i was first reading the
book and laying down these memories so
this like harry potter world for example
is kind of very intertwined with my own
personal life and my own personal story
and so it kind of adds layers and
dimension to my own personal memories of
my life experience and also adds the
whole areas of vibrancy and joy that are
very fun to kind of escape to when i
want to and i think it kind of really
promotes my imagination and prompts my
memories in a way that is absolutely
beautiful 10 out of 10 would recommend
reading fiction for this the third thing
is that books kind of switch on a radio
in my brain very often and what i mean
by this is for example you might be in a
empty quiet room and you might think
okay there is literally no sound in here
but if someone gave you radio and you
tuned it on to the right frequency you
can think oh yes there must be radio
waves because now i am hearing the sound
through the radio and reading books can
sometimes have this effect on me so for
example if i'm reading a story wherein
the author is kind of describing the
trees and a lot of detail and the way
that they move and the way that they
look and the way that their marks are
shaped and grow i feel as though the
next time i leave my house and look at
the tree i will appreciate it in a way
that i have never done before because
many different authors choose to focus
on different aspects of reality which
can be physical things such as trees or
certain ways that we experience the
world or certain characters or
characteristics about people like the
way that the hair flows in the main
protagonist or the way that um someone's
eyes sparkle i start to notice these
things in my own reality for a short
period of time after so i somehow adopt
the lens that the author uses to view
the world as my own and this can be
extremely fun it definitely adds like
vibrancy in my way of experiencing the
world and i can always tell after a book
i'm having the after effects of the
author's way of writing in my own
experience so i find that to be
extremely extremely fun the next thing
that books have done for me is kind of
unlock parts of my brain that i did not
have access to for example sometimes if
i'm feeling like bad i might name that
feeling as anxiety or stress or just
sadness but very often it feels quite
vague i don't actually know what is
causing it or what the feeling is i
fully believe that if i don't have
specific words to name feelings i just
don't have access to what that feeling
really is in the higher parts of my
brain so my subconscious might know what
it is and i but i am only consciously
aware that there's something brewing
down there but i don't know what it is
and sometimes i will read a book wherein
the author has an ability to describe
something very very similar to what i'm
feeling and suddenly something clicks in
my brain and i go oh my god yes that's
what i was feeling or that is why i did
that thing or that is why i felt a
certain way and i feel like authors have
such a great ability to do this probably
because they spend so much time like
years or months building up characters
and their experiences or because like i
said no one around me has gone through
this experience but the author has done
and so they've put it in a character in
their book or just because they have a
better grasp of literature and language
than i do so they just tend to name
things in a way that makes me unlock
that experience unlock that feeling in a
way that i couldn't do before if you're
looking for this sort of experience i
would definitely recommend classics
people like virginia woolf or
shakespeare have given i think so much
time into analyzing the human experience
and they are so gifted with words in
describing what they're thinking so well
that very very often with these two
authors i will find that kind of click
in my brain when i go oh my god yes this
is it of course you can get this effect
or much better effects through therapy
but i find to a lesser extent to get the
same thing through reading and my fifth
and final thing is that books have
helped me learn about my own brain and
what i mean by this is that i fully
believe that if two people were to read
the same book they would read it in two
completely different ways the reason for
that is every time i approach a book i
approach it with my own background with
my own judgment with my own baggage and
with my own ways of viewing things
therefore very often i will learn more
about myself from a book than i learned
from the book itself sometimes i will
sometimes i will read into something and
think oh this was definitely not what
the author meant but this is what i feel
and so the book will just kind of be the
key that unlocks that thing within
myself sometimes that will be blatantly
obvious sometimes it is a lot less
obvious and it will only come about when
i'm reading the summary of the book or
reading a forum on the book or if i'm
lucky enough to have someone else who
has read the book around me to discuss
it with them and realize maybe this is
just me and not what the author meant i
feel as though this path of
unintentional self-exploration that
books can put me on is absolutely
beautiful and i feel as though fiction
and philosophy are the best things for
this when it comes to myself i wanted to
keep this video short and sweet i'm
going to end it here but i hope any of
these made sense to you and if you could
please share your current struggles with
reading i would actually love to
potentially do a video on overcoming
those which might go in a bit more depth
but if you made it so far thank you so
much for spending this time with me i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be kind yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye